[Applause]
oh my god i love you so much i'm so
excited i love you oh my goodness this
is crazy and i love this clip because
it's about parenting and i have two
daughters i'm in the two girls club
you've got two boys
i do
are you a strict parent
uh
in between you know what i'm saying you
try to have boundaries i love the idea
of being able to have a friendship just
as long as he understands that like you
have to do what i tell you to do
like
you you me and your buddies as long as
you obey me but i i think the important
thing is that you want your kids to do
what you want them to do for their
well-being and out of love and not out
of fear that's a very good
differentiator
yeah
um is it true that your beautiful wife
who i love your love story with her how
you
were college sweethearts and then
there's the favorite story of you like
running in a suit next to her
um it seems like something out of a
movie when you realize like
you wanted her back is that true
that's that's totally true but ryan
michelle befay and i go back to freshman
year of college where we lived in the
same dorm and we did our first play
together and we found out that we were
both in st louis and we were both born
in the same hospital but we had to go 2
000 miles away to find each other and we
dated on and off like many young lovers
can
and after three and a half years being
out of each other's lives i realized
like oh my goodness this woman who i
thought was crazy was not crazy
she's just awesome and i wasn't able to
understand just how awesome she was
until she was out of my life and so i
found her and she was exercising and i
was wearing like dress clothes and like
you know uh dress shoes and she says
well sterling i can't talk right now i'm
going for a jog if you want to come with
me you can and so she had me jogging
like in my suit and dress shoes just
like running next to her while she's in
her athleisure where i said i think
you're the love of my life and she goes
really stirring she's running really is
that what you think and i say yeah i
think so and she goes well i guess
you're the love of my life too and then
here we are married 16 years next month
and her grandmother had a particular
feeling about you is that true
when we first got together we had the
most amazing
10 days
that two people who are in love have
ever had in the history of love and then
after ten days
my wife stopped talking to me and so
like a day or so later she told me
my grandmother had a dream about you
that you were going to hurt me so i had
to stop talking to you i was like
assistant
i said we're 20 21 years old your
grandmama had a dream
and so you gonna stop talking to your
boy and she's like i know but my
grandmother has sight so it took a
minute for me to convince her they're
like okay i i love and appreciate your
grandmother's sight but let's just try
to stay in the present for each other so
that's
that story but you're so
heartfelt and you're such a thoughtful
person and i'm hanging on your every
word as if i am watching your life like
a movie but it is your real life and you
are this person and i'm excited to talk
to you today about
this incredible endeavor
that is so meaningful
it's important to you it's talking about
cancer prevention
and how people with cancer can find a
support group when they're going through
the most difficult thing and how did you
get involved with this and i know it's
personal for you so will you tell us
about it
so 2004 i had an uncle my uncle sonny
passed away from cancer
and he passed away almost six months to
the day of his diagnosis it took him
fast
it was gut-wrenching for my family
so this program that i'm part of
survivorship today and you can check it
out at survivorship today.com
uh did it with bristol myers squid yep
and it's about living long term with
cancer and what your life is now like as
opposed to what it was before and it's a
series of conversations and testimonials
about what it means to go through
diagnosis go through treatment and now
to be living long term with this disease
whether it's in remission or not so
first and foremost it's for people who
have a cancer diagnosis who are
interested in what it's like and what
other people have gone through and to
hear their testimony about coming
through on the other side
so that's why i got involved and that's
why i think it's important and the
website may i say is very robust
thank you
thank you
for giving that outreach and connection
to something that is so ubiquitous
[Music]
you